so ein jahr echter braig cit liegt
hinter uns so lange sind die briten
jetzt raus aus zollunion und binnenmarkt
trotzdem wenig grund zum jubeln für
boris johnson oder wie selbst
parteifreunde ihn mittlerweile liebevoll
nennen dum dum boris ok liebevoll war
gelogen in dieser woche hat ihnen die
eigene partei die gefolgschaft
verweigert in sachen corona maßnahmen er
steht überhaupt tierisch unter druck
weil sein team weihnachts partys
gefeiert hat während die britischen
bürger im strengen lockdown waren man
könnte auch sagen für johnson ist der
brh exit bis jetzt wie dieser
regenschirm den du relativ schnell
aufspannen kannst dann aber merkst dass
du das ding lieber wieder loswerden
willst möchte aber keine haben also
versuchst du es noch mal neu und dann
fährst auch noch deine corona strategie
vor die wand
torchancen in seiner besten rolle als
mister bean britische
wirtschaftsexperten sagen der praxis
wirkt sich für die insel sogar noch
verheerender aus als die korona pandemie
eigentlich ist fast alles eingetreten
wovor sie vorher gewarnt haben also es
gibt jetzt chaos an den englischen
tankstellen benzinmangel und immer mal
wieder leere supermarktregale wegen
lieferproblemen und fachkräftemangel
komisch sagt man die ganzen polen und
rumänen rausgeschmissen hat will auf der
insel gar keiner mehr lkw fahren
zwischenzeitlich haben die busfahrer zu
brummifahrern gemacht um dann
festzustellen dass im bus fahrer fehlen
mysteriös wer irgendwer muss die zeile
halb fahren ist ja so dasselbe problem
bei den britischen schweinebauern auch
die finden keine schlachter mehr daher
wohl dieses unglaublich großzügige
angebot der regierung johnson downing
street will ausländische fachkräfte
jetzt mit befristeten visa locken der
haken noch vor weihnachten sollen alle
die jetzt händeringend gesucht werden
das land wieder verlassen
wieso haken so eine riesenchance für
osteuropäische lohnsklaven erst den
briten weihnachten retten und sich dann
nach hause verpissen will kaum einer
finde ich gut dass die da nicht
mitmachen boris johnson ist aber
menschlich enttäuscht und so geschockt
dass seine reden inzwischen man muss es
so hart sagen regelrecht will klingen
erst
nach der rede haben sie als hardcore
boris fans gesagt okay jetzt ist es
passiert offiziell google wirklich was
ist denn mit dem los man macht sich
sorgen hier brandneue folge von so heißt
es bei uns papa wutz
familie woods feiert weihnachten
jubeln peppa und schorsch
seid ihr bescheuert sagt mama woods ein
jahr bringt die geschenke sind alle noch
beim zoll in frankreich
[Musik]
nicht meine schuld boris johnson hat uns
in die scheiße geritten die dumme sau
bindung es klingelt an der tür es ist
boris johnson er sagt hallo ihr schweine
folgendes england hat dieses weihnachten
wegen wechsel zu wenig truthähne aber
viel zu viele schweine ihr müsst alle
gekeult werden und sogar hatten es auf
der illegalen weihnachtsfeier in der
downing street doch noch lecker
weihnachtsbraten ende
[Musik]
klassisches happy end und während putin
die ost ukraine bedroht und china taiwan
fragt man sich was ist die antwort des
so genannten freien westens nach einem
jahr präsidentschaft joe biden in den
usa
gerade wir deutschen haben ja gedacht
ohne trump hat das gute automatisch
gesiegt seit dem fluchtartigen abzug der
armee aus afghanistan ist zumindest ein
teil der beiden euphorie verflogen auch
seine regierung würde gern julian
assange dafür dass der us
kriegsverbrechen öffentlich gemacht hat
für 175 jahre einkerkern verheerendes
signal von kleineren protokoll pannen
mal ganz abgesehen so wie hier als er
beim glas chor klimagipfel nach all der
weltrettung ein kurzes powernapping
einlegt ja wie es ihn dann sein laden
los weckt gemein kurz danach kam
allerdings der viel schlimmere fauxpas
im smalltalk ausgerechnet mit camilla
parker bowles ist dem präsidenten ja
wohl was rausgerutscht in gegenwart der
herzogin von cornwall boards berichtete
schockiert von einem lauten geräusch das
nicht zu ignorieren war
keine frage auch so kann man natürlich
geschichte schreiben sogar netflix hat
bereits reagiert
[Musik]
memo an mich selbst grimme-preis
freiwillig zurückgeben
dabei bräuchte ist genau jetzt einen
topfiten joe biden denn sein vorgänger
greift nach der macht mit seinen
orangenen griffeln the return of the
donald während jeden tag neue details
ans licht kommen zum putschversuch vom 6
januar als ein mob von trump fans das
kapitel gestört und polizisten zum teil
mit pfefferspray und eisenstangen
angegriffen hat das war ein glasklarer
umsturzversuch angestiftet und
orchestriert von donald trump hochverrat
nennt man das 78 prozent seiner wähler
glauben trotzdem dass ihnen der wahlsieg
gestohlen wurde und leider gehen alle
experten davon aus dass trump 2024
wieder antritt der kollege claus von
wagner geht noch einen schritt weiter er
arbeitet neuerdings in trams golf
ressort malaga als caddie des früheren
und vielleicht kommenden präsidenten
klaus das ist erklärungsbedürftig ist es
nicht das ist einfach realistisch oder
glauben sie immer noch dass er mit
kabarett die welt retten kann
ich nicht es gibt nur noch eine hoffnung
zumindest während trump golf spielt kann
nicht am nächsten putzarbeiten deshalb
habe ich diesen job angenommen und
versuche jetzt ihnen rund um die uhr zu
loben fantastic ministerpräsident best 2
nr
juli
hat
gott ich hasse mich selbst aber anders
geht es nicht es wurde er kann doch beim
nächsten mal auch wieder verlieren eben
nicht am bearbeitet doch längst am slow
moving also so eine art putsch in
zeitlupe seine republikaner untergraben
von morgens bis abends das vertrauen ins
amerikanische basis tätig und leitete
gleichzeitig hunderte von maßnahmen ein
für eine niedrigere wahlbeteiligung von
minderheiten und jungen leuten auch
daniel craig
charakter baracke seine leute überlassen
nichts mehr dem zufall in georgia zum
beispiel gibt es jetzt viel weniger
wahllokale für freie wähler und wenn
sich dann lange schlangen ist es
verboten warten da anzusprechen oder
ihnen wasser und essen anzubieten in
texas kriegen vertreter der parteien
uneingeschränkten zugang zu wahllokalen
und können das stimmt zählen behindern
und wissen was das schlimmste ist
trump hat schon einen neuen schlachtzug
slogan
merkel
[Applaus]
kam
stellen sie sich das mal bei uns vor so
leute ist tritt wieder an wir machen
großdeutschland wieder wieder groß was
da los war
klar trampert seine fans fans aber die
mehrheit der amis hat ihnen ja
absichtlich nicht gewählt welche siams
immer noch nicht kapiert oder read my
lips mehrheiten gewinnen hier keine
wahlen es geht nur um die swing states
und da war es auch letztes jahr war der
terminus technicus herthas knapp trans
berühmte anruf beim wahlleiter von
georgia
[Musik]
es muss doch in einer demokratie möglich
sein stimmen zu finden wenn man richtig
sucht der wahlleiter hat sich damals
übrigens geweigert und wird garantiert
ausgetauscht genau wie all die anderen
raps die noch widerstand leisten und
weil facebook und twitter in spergau
trump jetzt mit spendengeldern sein
eigenes social network auf nennt sich
ruß social
was ganz ruhig ist weil wahrheit und
sozial die beiden vokabeln sind die am
wenigsten zu ihm passen
das sind die ersten 100 tage mit den
behauptungen von donald trump
ein katalog der falschen aussagen und
wie sie sehen hat es bisher nur drei
tage gegeben an denen er keine
unrichtigen behauptung von sich gegeben
hat und an zwei dieser drei tage war
golf spielen verstehen sie und deswegen
muss er noch viel viel mehr golf spielt
das problem seither kann
zwar
simply the best ministerpräsident boiko
wenn
er kein claus von wagner vielen dank
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und 70 - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]